so how was Vegas oh my God it was so
much fun we got like a limo and like so
you just glossing over that you forgot
about me you're just such a planner you
need like a week in advance sometimes
life is just like Kimberly you told me
30 minutes or you already on the plane I
think the group chat was going nuts the
group chat was like ushers are thing
yeah everyone going to Usher the first
time for her birthday that failed are we
Landing all right ladies and Gent little
bit ATC will not let us land in M we're
all starting a chat like bullying her
like you I can't believe you did this
without us all of us are pissed and
she's like I didn't know you guys would
be upset about
this yeah it was like we have to go back
like we H like it was so fun I'd go back
I'm going to get together the most fun
group and we are going to go see Usher
and Chloe is going to leave the gates of
his Hills whether she likes it or not